la loi de finances pour 2018 continue
une politique fiscale avantageuse de
niche pour les énergies fossiles qui
corrompt la petite bagatelle de 7
milliards d'euros au budget national
nous ne pouvons plus continuer ainsi à
manier le double discours comme encore
récemment lors du one planet ce mythe
derrière les promesses de dégradation de
l'économie
la réalité est tout autre après trois
années de stagnation les émissions
humaines de dioxyde de carbone sont
repartis à la hausse en 2017
c'est le constat des travaux publiés le
13 novembre dernier par quinze mille
scientifiques de 184 pays
cette tribune enjoint les responsables
politiques que nous sommes de tout
mettre en oeuvre pour freiner la
destruction de l'environnement et éviter
que ne s'aggrave
l'épuisement des ressources que
l'humanité tiers de la planète
le point de non retour est presque
atteint